what's up everyone its Warren and it's a
new month that means a new round of the
theory Thursday contest Theory Thursdays
is my new segment where you all submit
your theories for a chance to end up in
an episode and compete for the monthly
prize each week you will vote on your
favorite theory and at the end of the
month out of all the winners you vote on
your overall favorite theory be sure to
check out the video I did earlier on
today so you can vote on last month's
winner and I'll link it up above for
those of you who want to submit your own
theories for a chance to end up in an
episode you can find the directions and
the email in the description down below
okay let's get started with this week's
theories we have some really good ones
especially with the release of the new
Avengers in game footage that came with
the Super Bowl
so our first theory today comes from Max
he is 12 years old living in California
and he has a theory about the quantum
realm suits and Avengers end game max
thinks that the Avengers will wear the
quantum realm suits and go inside of the
quantum realm within the first 15 to 20
minutes of the movie max bases this
theory off of a couple things the first
one is that the president of Marvel
Studios Kevin Feige said that in the
teasers and the footage that we see for
Avengers in game that will be released
will only be from the first 15 to 20
minutes of the movie and with that comes
his second point which is he's not
buying that in the Avengers in game
Super Bowl TV trailer spot rocket is
wearing his old outfit from the comics
max doesn't believe this to be true he
thinks it's misdirection from the Russo
brothers
he thinks he's actually wearing his
quantum realm suit thanks to mini leaks
that we've gotten over the past couple
of months we have seen the Avengers in
these white and red new suits and it's
widely believed that these new suits
that the Avengers are wearing are
designed for traveling inside of the
quantum realm and this is the suit that
max thinks rocket is wearing in the
trailer he also says that rocket has
never worn a suit like this before in
guardians of the galaxy vol 1 he wore a
black suit and a black suit with orange
/ reddish color on it and in guardians
of the galaxy vol 2 and in Avengers
infinity war he wore a dark blue and
black suit and all of which are
basically sleeveless and the one in the
trailer has long sleeves and he actually
doesn't think that it looks
blugh he thinks this is misdirection in
the trailer in the movie he actually
thinks it's going to be a white or gray
in red suit used for traveling inside of
the quantum realm and the shed that he's
at is actually where Thor is at and that
rocket has gone to get Thor so he can go
with the rest of the Avengers inside of
the quantum realm so that's it for Max's
theory he certainly does have some good
points when it comes to rocket suit
rocket has never worn anything like this
suit before and everything that he has
worn willingly has been sleeveless or
short-sleeved and the Russo brothers are
known for their misdirection in their
trailers so this very well could be the
case and we do know thanks to the
Avengers in game Super Bowl TV spot that
Thor goes off somewhere looking for
something and he just spent a lot of
time with rockets so maybe rocket is the
one that goes off and brings Thor back
to regroup with the rest of the Avengers
to go inside of the quantum realm so
that does it for theory number one on to
theory number two theory number two
comes from John Spillman he's a teacher
and he has a theory on what he believes
could be key footage for Avengers
endgame John thinks that footage for
Avengers in game could have actually
been shown in the Avengers infinity war
trailers that we saw John says there are
obviously some discrepancies of what we
saw in the infinity war trailers and
what was actually shown in the movie
for example the Hulk running in Wakanda
and fighting alongside the Avengers when
the Hulk never came out past the first
scene of Avengers infinity war what if
this is actually footage from Avengers
end game since the Avengers will most
likely go back in time to change the
past to affect the future and in doing
so it creates a future where the Hulk
actually does come out and fights with
the Avengers in the battle of Wakanda
John says that another interesting
example is the Infinity stones missing
from Thanos his gauntlet while grappling
with Captain America and the Avengers
infinity war trailer there were Infinity
stones missing from the gauntlet in the
trailer but in the movie they were all
there what if this is a Thanos who never
found those particular Infinity stones
because the Avengers were able to
acquire them before he did again going
into the past to change the events of
the future this could be something very
clever done by the Russo brothers if
this is in fact a case instead of
putting what we thought were fake scenes
in the Infinity war trailer they
actually put scenes from Avengers
in game in their clues hidden in plain
sight this is definitely possible and I
wouldn't put it past the Russo brothers
the Russo brothers are some very sneaky
guys and I mean that in a very good way
I can definitely see the Avengers going
back in time altering the past to change
the future and us seeing the Hulk run
with the rest of the Avengers in Wakanda
in a final battle and Avengers in game
so I definitely think this theory is
interesting and has a lot of merit to it
so that's it for Theory 2 onto Theory
number three theory number three comes
from Gabby Grace who thinks the Russo
brothers are going to throw a huge
curveball at us by killing the original
six Avengers and war machine after the
original Avengers all die Nick Fury puts
together a new team of Avengers that
includes Captain Marvel spider-man
Scarlet Witch Falcon Bucky Barnes and
ant-man gabby says the Avengers die
because the Russo brothers say that we
don't know anything about Avengers in
game and we wouldn't expect all The
Avengers to die
we are only expecting Captain America
and/or Iron Man to die
gabi says it would also make sense
because we didn't see Iron Man in the
spider-man far from home trailer so he
may have died and one more reason is
that the Avengers most likely would get
involved if the elementals were
terrorizing cities and in the spider-man
far from home trailer we don't see any
of the Avengers the Russo brothers did
say that we really don't have any idea
about what's going to happen in Avengers
in game and I don't think anybody is
expecting all of the original Avengers
to die however many of their contracts
are up and we haven't heard any word
about them renewing them in fact we have
heard that some of them will in fact be
moving on from their characters so you
never know it just may happen that's
theory number three on to theory number
four theory number four comes from Adam
Rollins his theory is short and sweet
but is very very interesting Adams
theory is that some of the Avengers are
actually inside some of the Infinity
stones Gamora is in the soulstone a
version of vision is in the mine stone
Loki is in the reality stone because
where else would the trickster God go
and Doctor Strange is in the time stone
these four will work together to weaken
Thanos from inside his mind lessening
his resolve increasing his self-doubt
fighting his control over these stones
distracting him while the rest of the
Avengers do
they need to do to take down Thanos this
is certainly a theory that is thinking
outside of the box but it may not be as
far-fetched as it seems we know from the
comics that the sole world is inside of
the soul stone and the research said
that they're not going to repeat the
same stories from the comics because we
already know those stories but they do
draw inspiration from the comics so
perhaps instead of just having one sole
world inside of the soul stone there
could be other Avengers trapped inside
of the other Infinity stones and again
the Russo brothers said that we don't
really have any idea about what's going
to happen in Avengers endgame and I
don't think many people are expecting
this so you never know it could
definitely happen so that's it for
Theory number 4 on to the final Theory
theory number 5 theory number 5 comes
from Jordan gondola and Jordan has a
theory about the greater threat of
Avengers end game Jordan states that
since dr. strange was dusted in the
events of Avengers infinity war Dormammu
will realize that his deal with dr.
strange is no longer valid and once he
realizes that he will come to earth to
consume it presumably wanting to turn
all humans into his Dark Dimension
minions Jordan says that we are all
looking for who the second threat could
be and there are only really a few
people to choose from some main ones
being Dormammu or de lactis and since
Marvel doesn't technically own the
rights to Galactus yet it has to be
there Manu Jordan's theory actually
makes pretty good sense we know that
there's a second threat coming in
Avengers endgame thanks to some leaks in
a book that ties into the MCU and Doctor
Strange is dead and if their mom who
realizes that there's nothing to prevent
him from going to earth to consume it
there's no more threat of Doctor Strange
trapping him inside of a time loop so in
dormammu's mind why wouldn't he go back
to earth so he could very well be the
second threat in Avengers endgame so
there you have it your five theories for
this week's Theory Thursday let's do a
quick recap theory number one was that
rocket is actually wearing his quantum
realm suit in the Avengers in game Super
Bowl TV spot trailer and the Avengers
will go inside of the quantum realm
within the first 15 to 20 minutes of the
movie theory number two states that some
scenes that we thought were fake from
the Avengers infinity war trailer are
actually scenes from Avengers endgame
the Avengers go back in time in the past
that affects the future in which we see
the Hulk running with you
and fighting in Wakanda theory number
three states that the Russo brothers
will throw us a huge curveball and
actually kill the original six Avengers
and war machine this is because the
wrister brothers said that we really
have no idea what is going to happen in
Avengers in game and this would
certainly be a huge surprise to
everybody and from there Nick Fury will
assemble a new Avengers team theory
number four is that some heroes are
trapped inside of some of the Infinity
stones Gamora in the soulstone a version
of vision inside of the mine stone Loki
inside of the reality stone and Doctor
Strange inside of the time stone and
these four will work together to weaken
Thanos while the other Avengers defeat
him and the last theory number five is
that Dormammu is actually going to be
the greater threat and Avengers endgame
realizing that since Doctor Strange died
his deal with him is no longer valid so
he goes to earth to consume it so that
does it for this week's theories for
Theory Thursdays be sure to vote on
which theory you think should win this
week and if you have theories of your
own and want a chance to possibly end up
in an episode of Theory Thursdays you
can send them to cosmic Theory Thursdays
at gmail.com and you can find the
directions in the description down below
don't forget to subscribe with the
notifications turned on so you don't
miss an episode of Theory Thursdays and
so you can stay up to date on everything
Marvel related as always thank you all
so much for watching
Wolf Wolf
[Music]